from the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jason
from Minnesota stopped by with a
question hey Jason how are you
you're good sir thank you good good how
can I help sir
well my father-in-law and I actually
co-owned eight fast casual restaurants
together and just created four tough
family dynamics and I actually called
you back in 2008 prior to getting into
all this and you told me not to do it
but here we are okay so eight
restaurants deep intermingled my
question is do I sell some of the stores
to create room from him or do I look at
maybe just a refinance we've paid down
quite a bit of the debt majorities SBA
loans but um
step one is just to get separation from
him on the business side okay does he
want out completely no he would still
own four and I would have force that's
been quite a conversation just to get
who owns what as far as where's middle
ground
okay and how much is owed on the package
um some real estate involved also but
for the four stores I'd be looking at
would be around 800 okay and does that
include real estate no real estate on my
end but each store would be worth around
500 to 800 apiece okay all right so you
could sell one and have three free and
clear pretty close and you wouldn't do
that why um two of them in the same city
so I would sell them together one is in
our hometown which I would probably hold
on to and one of them I have actually
offered and it's kind of in some
conversation with Anna a manager has
been with me 10 years to possibly buy
that one so if he buys that one why
would you not have $800,000 from
well I could I could I just didn't know
from kind of a paid for real estate
piece once I refinance I feel like I
could really reduce the debt load fast
if I sell if you guys can split it off
and you end up with eight hundred
thousand dollars in debt in your name
not his name is that possible yes why
haven't you already done that I was
trying to come to an agreement as to who
owns what stores and with real estate
and family that way so you've got the
four picked out that you want he doesn't
want you to have those four no we've
agreed at that now so okay it's settled
it so thus far as the resigning is yes
separation not done nothing since f
Romania is the concept of the separation
all the decisions have been made right
yes you've got four stores he's got four
stores so you're asking me how to
separate from him and yet you've already
done it well legally I'm still on for
all eight I'm still on the hook for all
eight so I didn't know as my step one to
sell store where's my stuff i refined
who separated them why are you on the
hook for the other four
we've only separated by checkbooks
I mean I'm controlling the four
checkbooks but legally SBA loans leases
everything's intermingled okay so you
haven't separated then you still are
just with checkbook just operationally
is all but not an ownership stand for
correct okay and so how are you gonna
separate I mean I get how you could pay
off eight hundred by selling one or
getting close right of your four you'd
be clear except you're still
intermingled on all this other crap how
you gonna get out of that the stuff
that's on his for that's that's where
once there F of refinance is step one or
selling is step one then we can start to
change business names and start to move
forward with your name off of the leases
and the loans that are on his for it's a
verbal agreement at this point like I
say it's my father-in-law so no no no
are the banks gonna release you yes okay
when once the SBA's are paid off then
you take him on in just himself and I'm
taking him on as myself with four and
four opposed to
what are the SBA's the 800 um well 800
is just on the four that I would have
it's closer to two though I know are you
gonna get the other SBA loans paid off
on the four he has he would refinance
under himself so he'd be responsible for
that debt I just be assuming half of it
okay and why is that not underway it
took it took a while to get to the point
to agree on four and four but now we've
agreed when those that agreement
established um probably within the month
okay all right so he needs to go
refinance and get your name off the
SBA's he can get your name off the
leases as well you personally guaranteed
the leases I have contacts with all the
landlord so I would definitely start
there it's just a matter of get the
financing right then takes it up to yeah
well he's it's on him to refinance the
portion of SBA that's on those other
four stores you're waiting on him to do
that you can't make his decision for him
on that I would need to make it on my
four so I'm asking should I should sell
one of them that's what I just said yeah
yeah you know yeah I'll be out of debt
and I'd be clearing my father-in-law
yeah and uh you know what come what will
the manager buy that one store for that
you promised the manager mmm 750 okay
and you owe 800 so you need 50 grand you
probably borrow 50 grand on those three
stores yeah as a temporary thing and
then try and get it paid off and your
hundred percent debt free didn't
understand that right
Oh three home but business but you know
you own three stores free and clear yes
and you're free and clear your
father-in-law yeah I hear peace and
tranquility in your life brother
Thanksgiving dinner would taste
different yeah well I mean you know you
don't have any debt a year from the day
after you run through all this crap and
your but you have three paid for stores
that you know how to run and you don't
have a partner anymore that your
father-in-law I love this yeah that's
where you need to go yeah but you're
already here yeah but no I would not
refinance it and then try to pay off 800
grand that's what got you into this
dadgum mess is violating all these
principles of debt and partnerships so
go back to a clean life with no debt and
no partners and you're gonna love your
life and guess what in eight
to 24 months those three stores are
gonna generate enough for you to buy
another one probably because you need
stinking payments anymore you know I
mean by riding your butt all the time
you can just run the things properly and
don't have anybody to bother you no
bankers no father-in-law's if you if you
got all that off of you if you know how
to operate these restaurants you should
be able to make some serious Bank on
them these are franchises aren't they
correct yeah okay so that it's a cookie
cutter machine is what it should be if
you're not all weighed down with
relational and debt problems agreed yeah
it's worth it man
cut them one loose let the manager have
his store let him go get his money give
you 750 you owe 50 you clear that up
real quick
get off the SBA loan with the
father-in-law get off the leases with
the father-in-law and you're clear I
think I've got this straight that I
understand everything yeah you've got
majority of it that's what I want here
yeah thank you head to peace and
tranquility and simplicity
you will then operate much more
efficiently and more profitably and that
will cause your long-term prosperity you
are taking a small step back to be able
to take a whole bunch forward good
question thanks for joining us